- Let's talk about Tyreek Hill,
the Kansas City
Chiefs' wide receiver
who is being investigated
according to the
Kansas City Star
and Overland Park Police who say
they are investigating
two incidents,
including one where a
source from the Star
believes that his three-year-old
son broke his arm.
- They're not investigating
the three-year-old son
broke his arm,
they're investigating
that Tyreek Hill
broke his son's arm.
- Right.
- Yeah, you didn't say that.
- I said it was a
domestic assault case.
I think people can
put it together.
- No, if they investigate
the son broke his arm,
but they're saying
Tyreek did it.
It wasn't the mom,
he didn't just fall,
he didn't fall out
of a fucking tree,
Tyreek Hill broke
his own son's arm.
- Well they haven't
charged him yet,
so it's a little, careful.
- But that's what
they're investigating,
that's the story, allegedly.
It's a domestic violence
story with a twist,
you know what I mean?
It's a kid this time,
which I always enjoy.
(Erica laughs)
We do a lot of you know,
they're beating up women,
I don't like that.
It's a boy, it's a
three-year-old boy,
then we can have some
fun with the topic,
you know what I mean?
Then we can kind of mess around.
When I saw the story,
my first thought was
what did the kid do,
you know what I mean?
They never asked that.
When, who's the running
back who beat his kid
with a switch?
- Adrian Peterson.
- Adrian Peterson never
explained what his kid did
to deserve that, do
you know what I mean?
He was just like, I
punish my kid sometimes,
I hit him a little too hard.
He never said like, if
he had been like the kid,
you know, put oatmeal
in my DVD player,
then we'd be like okay,
maybe you were justified.
So I want to know what
Tyreek Hill, like,
what the kid did that
Tyreek Hill had to
allegedly break his
three-year-old son's
arm over his knee
which is how I imagine it,
that's how I imagine
he broke the arm.
How would you picture it, Gregg?
- I wouldn't.
- You think he maybe
threw him down some stairs
kind of thing, or like just
picked him up by an arm
and broke it?
Do you think maybe
they were playing?
- While you say it's kind
of more fun to play around
with the kid angle of it, it
does involve the kid's mom
as another person
involved, separate,
and she was also
someone he beat up
in a domestic assault in
college and pled guilty it,
while she was pregnant
with this kid.
So there's levels,
there's levels to it.
- Gregg, how did he get drafted
if he got charged with
domestic violence in college?
How'd that slip through
the cracks of the NFL?
- He got drafted a little later.
- Did the people find
out after he got drafted
that it happened?
- People knew ahead of time.
- They knew it all
the time, yeah?
Was there a chance that
the kid broke his arm
when Tyreek Hill beat
up his pregnant mom
and then they didn't find
out about it until later on?
(Erica laughs)
- Three years?
- I've never seen you guys
so uncomfortable with a story
before, I hope we use this
as part of the YouTube video
because Gregg is
so uncomfortable.
- I'm not.
- Erica gasped, which
I've never heard before.
Listen, it's a three-year-old.
- Look, I made it
through the Kraft week,
I think I can survive.
- Getting his arm broken
by his own father.
- [Gregg] Yeah.
- And how was Tyreek Hill
this year, as a player?
Did he have a good season?
- He was good enough
that there was a report
on our network about a month ago
that they were
discussing a contract
which might make him the
highest paid wide receiver
in the league.
- Really, okay.
- That was before this came out.
- So he earned this, in a
way, you know what I mean?
You're allowed, and
listen, here's the thing.
You break an arm, you
break a bone in your body,
this is science, you
it heals and it's
stronger than ever before.
You can never break it
in that place again.
Isn't that what
parenting's all about,
preparing your
children for the world?
- What is this medical
science you speak of
that it's stronger than before?
- It's a fact, it's a fact.
When a bone breaks,
when it heals
you can never break the
bone in that same place.
It's like, it's break-proof.
- (laughs) That's such nonsense.
- That's the medical
term, break-proof.
If you're a doctor and
you're listening to this.
- You make it sound like
it's one of those lizards
where you cut the head
off and it can grow again,
grow like another arm.
- If you cut off the
tip of a baby's finger
it will grow back.
I saw that on Twitter
once, on a WTF Facts,
that that's true.
- As a result, there
may be a brief period
in the healing process
when the fracture site
is stronger than the
surrounding bone.
- A brief period.
- But they later
reach equal strength,
and the fracture site is
no more or less likely
to break again.
- What'd you read that on?
- NewYorkTimes.com.
- I though in general
if you break a leg
you're more likely to break it
cuz it just shows you're
kinda prone to it.
- No, you're thinking of
dislocating an arm or a leg--
- Shoulder.
- Or something, yeah,
then it's gonna
happen all the time.
So Tyreek Hill didn't do
that, he was smart enough
not to dislocate his son's arm.
But I want to know
what the kid did.
Listen, okay?
If Walker hadn't
turned it around,
and Walker's four, he's
probably past the age
where you can break his arm.
(Erica and Gregg laugh)
But if he's three
then I think sometimes
you gotta teach them a lesson,
and there's no better
lesson than breaking him.
He didn't burn the kid,
which he could have done,
depending on what the
kid did, I don't know.
Maybe the kid didn't do
anything and Tyreek Hill
confused him for another
kid that did something?
- Well it would
seem that no matter
what a three-year-old
did, you know,
it wouldn't be worthy
of breaking his arm.
(Erica laughs)
- I mean not for me, you know?
But again, I'm not a father.
- Apparently.
- I don't know the
joy of being a father
and disciplining your own child.
- Neither do I.
- Actually I guess I can tell,
I've been around your kids,
they've never been disciplined.
(Erica laughs)
But if they were my kids,
they'd be in casts right now.
- A Jesus Christ
statue in a small--
- No, no, that's not a statue.
- They called it a statue.
- It's a doll.
- It's a doll, but
they call it a statue
because it's up in a house
and they have it
prominently displayed.
- You don't turn a
doll into a statue
by putting it up in a house.
- That's what they call it,
(Erica laughs)
that's what they're calling it.
Residents of a small
village in Acapulco, Mexico
are concerned because they claim
that for the fourth
time this year
this baby Jesus doll
has started crying blood.
- My favorite part
of the story is,
cuz I read the story
and it was like a doll
that they claim is
a baby Jesus doll.
It's not like an official
like TM baby Jesus doll,
it's just a baby doll
that they're like
this could be Jesus.
It looks just like
a regular baby doll.
- Yeah, I'm a little confused
why it's a baby Jesus doll.
- It looks like a girl.
- Especially with the
very professional looking
blood (Erica sighs)
coming out of its eyes.
- It looks like a girl
that Tyreek Hill babysat.
(Gregg and Erica laugh)
Allegedly.
- It's a baby
wearing a bib, too,
like is Jesus wearing a bib--
- Yeah and it's got like a hat.
- And a hat that
says Bear on it.
- I thought the baby
doll would have like
a beard and long
hair, but it doesn't,
and that's what Jesus
was all about from birth.
If you guys read the story
of the nativity scene,
baby Jesus, full beard
when he was born.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- So they are concerned
in this village that--
- But aren't they excited,
they're like oh this is like,
some people think
it's a good thing,
like this is God saying hey,
what's up, Acapulco rules.
And some people are saying
oh, maybe it's the devil.
- Right, one woman said, yeah,
a lot of people have said
it's done by the devil,
others think it's
a message from God.
They believe that the
statue's crying is
in direct response to
the amount of murders
in that village, in
which there are many.
- And it's not just
crying, it's crying blood.
- Crying blood.
- [Anthony] Which is
a whole other level.
- It happened first
on New Year's Day,
and it's happened three
more times since, this year.
- I would love to know
who noticed it first.
Who was like hey, what's up?
- It's in someone's house.
- No one's like hey,
is that ketchup?
(Erica laughs)
Like I don't believe
that dolls cry blood.
That's probably not
a baby Jesus doll.
Dolls mostly don't cry blood.
Did you play with dolls
when you were a kid, Erica?
- Yes.
- Did any of them cry blood?
- Never.
- Never, not even
when you rapped?
- No. (laughs)
- No?
Cuz I would think
that would do it.
Gregg, how do you feel
about this Jesus doll,
do you think it's legit?
- I mean, I thought the most
telling part of the story
was from an unnamed priest
and representative of
the Catholic Church
that will maybe go to
this person's house,
cuz they're afraid to
bring the baby doll
into the local church
because that might upset God,
and so they want to
leave it where it is.
But he said the Catholic
Church is gonna come,
they're gonna check it
out, and he did admit
a rational explanation
could be at play here
because not everything is
a spiritual phenomenon.
- That's true.
- You think?
(Erica laughs)
- Whoa, whoa.
Was that sarcasm at the end?
I love that the Catholic
Church can find a miracle
if they need it, you
know what I mean?
If you wanted to make a
new saint, it's like oh,
this was kind of a miracle.
But if you actually say
oh, what about this?
The Bible's full of stuff
that you wouldn't believe now.
If you were like hey, Erica
turned water into wine,
is that a miracle,
maybe she's a saint?
They'd be like no,
it's total bullshit.
When you read it in the Bible,
in the King James version,
I don't know how many
versions you've read
but the King James
is the best one,
then they're like that
makes perfect sense,
that's what happened.
- I just like, like how
does this become a story?
Who's idea was it to try
to make this a story?
- There are two kinds of
stories coming out of Mexico.
One is there's a caravan coming,
another one is a drug dealer
shot up a lot of people,
and the third one
is Jesus is crying.
It happens all the time.
Wasn't there like a
Virgin Mary statue?
- Yeah, a very similar--
- That they thought was
crying and it turned out
it was sewage coming,
it was like backed up sewage
(Erica groans)
coming out of their eyes, right?
- A very similar one
happened last year, yes.
So my thought was
probably the doll people,
whoever has this in their house
thought that got some good pop,
they're upset about all the
murders going on in town
and they gussied up this
doll with some eye blood.
- You know, I call myself
an atheist or an apatheist,
I don't care if there's a God,
but whenever I hear
about a baby doll,
a Jesus baby doll crying
blood, I think you know what?
Who knows for sure,
maybe there is a heaven
and I don't want to go there.
(upbeat rock music)
(Comedy Central jingle)